25e journée mondiale du refus de la
misère ce 17 octobre thème de cette
édition les brutalités symbolique ou
réelle imposées aux plus démunis une
date anniversaire qui intervient à un
moment où l'exclusion croît de manière
alarmante en france selon les derniers
chiffres de l'insee le taux de pauvreté
a atteint 14,1 pour cent en 2010 son
plus haut niveau depuis 1997 on écoute
dominique vienne il est le responsable
de l'organisation atd quart monde dans
le département des yvelines il était sur
ce plateau avec nous il ya quelques
jours et nous expliquer les actions
qu'ils menaient au quotidien atd quart
monde et un mouvement qui a été créée il
ya maintenant plus de 50 ans puisque dès
la fin des années 50 dekra est créé dans
un camp de sans logis à noisy-le-grand
dans l'est de la région parisienne sur
ces idées là voilà
l'assistance est une bonne chose mais
elle ne suffit pas loin de là il faut
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des personnes qui sont exclues puisse
retrouver l'accès à leurs droits
fondamentaux alors l'accès aux d'enfants
dans mon tour n'a incité quelques uns a
déjà c'est l'habitat c'est surtout
l'éducation et la culture c'est le
travail c'est cesser le fait de pouvoir
vivre en famille les grands moyens
d'action qu'on a qu'on a préconisé c'est
qu'il faut absolument faire en sorte que
ceux-ci l'once soit rompu donc il faut
aller aux gens de ces populations les
plus exclues et puis incité les pouvoirs
publics alors là vous m'interrogez sur
l'action d'intel et gardons d'une façon
générale l'autre aspect de l'action j'ai
qu'est la présence auprès des
populations les plus exclues l'autre
aspect c'est d'être très présent sur le
plan politique je dirais sans options
politiques mais ce qu'on veut c'est
éveiller les consciences des citoyens
éveiller les consciences des hommes
politiques sur ces problématiques l'a
donc le la grosse la grosse la grande
solution également
après poney se soit efforcé chacun d'eux
rompent le silence c'est d'inciter les
pouvoirs publics à aller au devant de
ces personnes les plus exclues de
rétablir le dire